[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour un
nouveau rendez vous de dimanche en
politique rendez vous exceptionnel
aujourd'hui à une semaine des élections
européennes pour laquelle trente quatre
listes sont en lice en france
c'est notre deuxième débat en bourgogne
franche comté avec des candidates et des
candidats ils sont six sur notre plateau
merci d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
arnaud danjean bonjour bonjour
bourguignon bressan vous êtes député
européen sortant depuis 2009 à
strasbourg et bruxelles dans les rangs
du ppe et pour ces élections numéro 3 de
la liste
lr bonjour jérémy de serre bonjour
autres candidats de saône et loire vous
êtes le numéro quatre de la liste elle
errait modem agriculteur éleveur de
charolais on vous connaissait jusqu'à
cette campagne comme le président
national des jeunes agriculteurs
miloud semaine bonjour joueurs vous
travaillez vous aussi dans l'agriculture
à charnay-lès-mâcon vous êtes en 25e
position sur la liste génération
le mouvement de benoît hamon au terme
d'une démarche originale puisque vous
avez postulé sur internet avant d'être
retenu pour cette campagne
bonjour myriam elias a besoin vous
représentez votre parti le ps vous êtes
conseiller municipal à besançon et vous
êtes en 4 44e position sur la liste ps
place publique c'est ça plus tard en
face de vous julien audy le bonjour
bonjour élus dans l'yonne en 31e
position sur la liste du rassemblement
national dont vous présidez par ailleurs
le groupe au conseil régional de
bourgogne franche comté
enfin isabelle liront bonjour
syndicaliste salariés à pôle emploi dans
la nièvre vous êtes en 34e position sur
la liste du parti communiste emmené par
ian brossât
au menu aujourd'hui donc pour notre
deuxième débat agriculture le premier
budget de l'union frontière avec le
dossier des migrations et emploi avec
cette question la politique menée par
l'union favorise-t-elle l'emploi dans
les pays membres
on va rappeler que le taux de chômage
c'est 6 5% en moyenne
mais il va de 2,1 en tchéquie 3,2 en
allemagne a plus voir beaucoup plus que
cette moyenne chez les quatre gros du
sud la france l'italie l'espagne et la
grèce alors accords commerciaux
protectionnisme protection sociale ou
marché du travail ou vers quelle est
votre vision arnaud danjean en tant
qu'élu sortant l'europe est-elle ce
qu'il faut pour les emplois de ces pays
d'abord ce n'est pas l'union européenne
qui créent ou qui crée pas de l'emploi
s'est pas c'est pas une puissance
publique européenne qui doit créer
l'emploi l'emploi c'est les entreprises
qui le qu'il a créé et c'est chaque pays
qui a aussi des politiques en la matière
et donc l'europe faire des grands
investissements nous nous prenons
d'ailleurs une europe des projets qui
pourraient dans certains domaines
relancer des grands des grands projets
qu'ils soient d'infrastructures ou des
projets de recherche qui sont en mesure
de générer de l'emploi et de la
croissance c'est important il faut
qu'ils aient des crédits européens qui
soient dédiés à des choses productive ça
c'est certain
et puis par ailleurs il faut
effectivement mettre fin à un certain
nombre de d'abus qui sont aujourd'hui
sont de l'ordre du dumping social ce
qu'on appelle du dumping social c'est à
dire qu'il faut que nos entreprises nos
artisans nos agriculteurs soient à
égalité dans un marché européen qui est
un marché unique et qui restera un
marché unique pour parler d'un pic à
l'intérieur de l'extérieur je pense que
là la vraie préoccupation ce qui
aujourd'hui est perçu comme
particulièrement pénalisant par nos
concitoyens et par nos entrepreneurs nos
artisans de l'agriculteur c'est de subir
c'est d'être dans un marché qui est
unique mais avec des règles qui faussent
la concurrence entre européens ça c'est
devenu insupportable et donc il ya un
certain nombre de secteurs qui sont plus
sensibles que d'autres je pense au
transport routier je pense évidemment à
l'agriculture je pense aussi aux
bâtiments qui sont des secteurs
importants de notre région d'ailleurs où
cette concurrence déloyale est devenu
insupportable donc il faut corriger ça
il ya indéniablement un effort à faire
en matière de convergence fiscale mais
là dessus et tout le monde en parle je
dirai tout le monde a bien identifié le
problème après les solutions qui sont
préconisées je pense qu'il faut être
réaliste la convergence états les états
ce qu'on veut que l'on préfère la
convergence sociale il faut bien être
conscient que c'est pas du tout ce que
propose madame l'oiseau par exemple avec
un smic partout en europe
parce que ces règles là il ya beaucoup
d'européens qui n'en veulent pas et
c'est pas parce qu'il ya des choses qui
marchent pas en france qu'il faut
vouloir les exporter en europe alors sur
la fiscalité et sur le social il faut
être conscient que sur la fiscalité sur
le social la france est un modèle
repoussoir pour la plupart des européens
donc s'il ya quelque chose qui se fait
en europe ça sera certainement pas sur
le modèle français parfait donc il faut
il faut travailler à une convergence
convergence ne voulant pas dire qu'on
obtiendra demain une harmonisation pure
et parfaite
on va revenir à ça vous parlez beaucoup
de l'intérieur julien doute vous dans
votre programme
vous situer plutôt sur les frontières la
limite extérieure de l'europe en
demandant en gros de protéger l'europe
contre contre le contrôle étranger c'est
pour vous deux conditions à la création
d'emplois c'est protéger surtout les
travailleurs européens et notamment les
travailleurs français
il ya une très belle phrase d'hubert
védrine ancien ministre qui est dit
l'union européenne c'est l'idiot dû
village global et c'est vrai puisque
aujourd'hui actuellement il ya zéro pour
cent des marchés publics qui sont
ouverts aux entreprises de l'union
européenne dans des pays comme la russie
comme l'inde comme le brésil comme la
chine alors que 100% des marchés publics
sont en union européenne sont ouverts à
l'étranger dont qui est même temps qu
art dont je vous coupe mais il ya quand
même un certain nombre de mesures qui
sont prises contre les importations
chinoises par exemple on sait que les
importations chinoises en europe ont
beaucoup plus taxés que les autres
travaillent six nommés existe mais c'est
extrêmement dérisoire est ce qu'on
constate c'est une concurrence déloyale
évidemment vis-à-vis de l'étranger hors
de l'union européenne
mais au sein même de l'union européenne
avec les travailleurs détachés quand
vous sachez qu'en en france donc on a
cinq cent seize mille travailleurs
détachés
on a dans notre région 23000 23me
n'était que 2800 il ya trois ans donc et
une explosion ont fait des travailleurs
l'énergie vient des prêts travail oui
mais c'est une réforme est une réforme
est qui ne va pas résoudre le problème
il est évident qu'il faut protéger nos
travailleurs protéger nos artisans nos
agriculteurs puisque cette concurrence
déloyale
c'est autant de chômage dans notre
région mais là ça le ps on va le
rappeler était dans la majorité au
parlement européen avec avec le ppe
s'est raccourci rapide voilà personnes
en majorité alors c'était le point de
départ c'était le point de départ de ma
question j'admets que le nom mais je je
je je concède si vous le concède non
tout tout ça pour dire que il ya eu un
certain nombre de décisions qui ont été
prises au niveau du parlement mais est
ce que on est allé assez loin pour vous
dans la création d'emplois en europe
vous aujourd'hui sur cette liste ps
placent vite par rapport à ce qui a été
fait le précédemment jusque là mais je
voulais rappeler que le ps était aussi
en partie pouvait être en partie
comptable de ce qui avait été d'ailleurs
nous allons envoyer des eurodéputés de
justement dans ce groupe le groupe
social-démocrate et on a pour ambition
qu'il devienne majoritaire dès le 27 mai
puisqu'on à une occlusion une occasion
unique en faisant alliance avec les
espagnols et les belges ne seront pas
parce que dans ce pays on va essayer
d'arriver à temps en temps ce qu'on fait
pour qu'on est évident qu'on a de voir
d'acculturation et près des citoyens
justement pour dire qu' il ne faut pas
transformer ce débat on à référendum
national et ton pour ou contre aimé
garder ma carapace qu'on voit sur le
plan valent à elles qu'elles regardent
jérémy de serre à les enjeux européens
sont beaucoup plus stratégique
est ce cela engage alors on fait quoi
sur l'emploi on fait quoi est ce qu'on a
fait à cs que a passé des accords de
libre échange c'est utile est ce qu'il
faut faire autrement et ce qu'il faut
fermer les frontières quelle est votre
vision
disons que c'est une vision un peu
courte d'imaginer qu'on puisse fermer
les frontières on peut les surveiller on
peut grâce à l'agent ce contexte non
parce que je parlais des frontières
économiques et frontières les
importations excusez moi les
importations et cetera non il faut
réguler le commerce effectivement et je
voudrais rebondir sur la question de la
fiscalité qu'elle soit plus juste et
plus équitable
alors oui les gars femmes par exemple
son créateur de ressources de recherche
de richesses d'emplois
néanmoins il faut instaurer une
fiscalité juste bruno le maire
malheureusement avait échoué alors
qu'ils avaient une volonté justement
deux filles de taxer les gars femmes
nous ce qu'on propose sur notre liste sa
proposition 97 c'est d'instaurer un taux
minimum de 20 % d'impôt sur les sociétés
on veut aussi instaurer un isf européens
tandis qu'au national certes à la broche
on veut aussi protéger les services
publics parce qu'ils sont créateurs
d'emplois et l'avenir de l'europe c'est
aussi investir massivement dans la
recherche et dans l'éducation pour
sachant que la vision du service public
elle n'est pas la même d'un pays à
l'autre
exactement au danemark pompiers s'est
privé par exemple tout à fait donc c'est
compliqué mais justement on relève le
défi notre ambition au niveau européen
avec les sociaux démocrates et tous les
eurodéputés progressiste et on compte
notamment sur l'expert
danse de sylvie guillaume qui est je le
rappelle la seule vice présidente
française du parlement européen pour
nous tuer les pour nous accompagner pour
permettre justement d'investir
massivement dans des politiques qui
renforce le service public dans des
politiques aussi qui met l'humain au
coeur du projet de société
j'ai envie de serre le arnaud danjean
vous cibler l'entrée en parlant de
bâtiments ce que votre tête de liste
évoque sur ainsi l'éventualité d'un smic
européen dont on sait qu'il ya des
différences absolument gigantesque entre
la bulgarie la france par exemple ou
luxembourg et que surtout ça correspond
à l'économie des pays et que l'on
imagine mal ces pays-là augmenter leur
salaire minimum en fonction de leur
économie est ce que c'est est ce que
c'est une solution ou est ce que c'est
un argument de campagne les deux je
crois que vu le constat que nous venons
tous de faire sur les difficultés qui
est qu'il y a et que l'europe rencontre
à cause de cette disparité nous oblige
et nous responsabilise pour faire des
choses parfois nous nous pensons qu'un
salaire minimum par les deux smic unis
quand le salaire médian on ne fait pas
de salir les deux smic unique
on dit que si on veut arrêter vous les
avez dit les disparités mais on peut
donner des chiffres 300 euros en
bulgarie moins de 300 euros en bulgarie
2000 euros au luxembourg on peut se dire
on laisse comme ça non ce que nous
voulons nous c'est reed réduire ces
disparités en essayant effectivement
d'avoir une solution ambitieuse
on n'a pas dit qu'on n'y arriverait
demain matin mais une solution
ambitieuse avec un smic
sa santé est d'accueillir le smic
français de 300 euros
il faut quand même le dire mais qui
paraît que je connais mieux le rendez
vous c'est 8 180 euros que je sois 300
euros de moins que je connais mieux le
programme que vous mais pour l'instant
la proposition était généralisé amour je
prévois que la proposition d'un record
porte mis sur la table les missions à
table à l'est
la roulette et bien toujours là c'est
assez particulier quand même n'est ce
pas répondre alors qu'on essaye de
trouver des solutions enfin bon bref
donc nous nous souhaitons en tout cas
avoir des propositions ambitieuses ça
bien sûr que le smic européen s'est pas
réalisable tout de suite mais ça répond
ça répondra aussi si on le met en place
correctement avec l'appui d'un certain
nombre de pays ça répondra aussi aux
problématiques d'harmonisation face aux
travailleurs détachés notamment est-ce
qu'on a encore d'accord notamment pour
l'agriculture est ce que c'était
beaucoup évoqué que des bêtes qui se
font abattre en allemagne ça coûte 30%
moins cher qu'en france
et bien non on n'est plus d'accord et
pourquoi c'est comme ça parce qu'il ya
des ouvriers polonais qui sont en danger
si je reviens on est dans du travail
détaché en allemagne une fiscalité en
france qui vous taxent les abattoirs
beaucoup plus qu'en allemagne contraire
mais ça vous le redire ça vous y redire
aux allemands il faut baisser vos taxes
ils vous diront pas fait le ménage chez
vous d'abord et bien mais ça veut pas ça
veut pas dire qu'on doit pas harmonisée
aussi nous et nous on veut harmoniser
par leurs homologues à celle en tout cas
notre envol et réagir sur le sujet quel
est le sens de faire des solutions
faudrait peut-être faire une mise à jour
ici tous autant que vous êtes vous
semblez ignorer qu'en 2016 le parlement
européen
il a fait voter sous l'impulsion de
guillaume balas qui est sur notre liste
il a fait voter une recommandation une
recommandation pour un smic à hauteur de
60% dans les états européens
donc en france 60% du salaire moyen
donc en france ça correspond à quoi ça
correspond à 1350 euros nets déjà si on
allait vers ça ça serait intéressant
mais le chef d'entreprise bulgare vous
allez lui permet de faire faillite si
vous imposez ça mais à écouter écouter
la pressée des discussions avec les
partenaires sociaux
bien évidemment on sait très bien
comment ça se passe aujourd'hui quelle
est la réalité du le constat c'est quoi
c'est qu'il ya des millions de personnes
en europe qui cherchent un emploi
côté ça il ya des millions de personnes
aussi qui ont un emploi mais qui sont
quand même dans les situations très
différentes d'un pédalo quand même
d'accord qu elle même des pays qui sont
à 3 4 % de taux de chômage
tout à fait ouais mais globalement parce
qu'on parle à l'échelle européenne il ya
des millions de personnes qui
aujourd'hui ont un emploi mais qui sont
quand même dans les situations de
précarité parce qu'ils sont mal payés
souper
ces cinq dernières années qu'est ce qui
s'est passé en europe il ya eu des
mouvements sociaux en france en espagne
en pologne dans pas moins de six pays
européens et qu'est ce qu'il demande la
même chose c'est-à-dire une meilleure
répartition des richesses
savez-vous à génération on n'est pas des
économistes en puissance à constance est
pas on va voir ceux qui le sont krugman
stiglitz qui sont deux économies ce prix
nobel d'économie américain et qui
connaissent particulièrement bien avec
le mur bien sûr ben ali se il suffit pas
d'être américain pour d'autres
universitaires américains les grandes
théories sur leurs hôtes mais toujours
est il qu'ils sont pas toujours est il
qu est ce qu'ils ont dit sur l'europe
ils ont ils ont dit qu'il fallait
investir massivement en europe afin de
booster l'économie et le marché de
l'emploi ce qu'elle était en partie le
plan juncker d'investissement ok ça
m'endort mais c'est pas suffisant
donc nous qu'est ce qu'on propose on
propose de ce qu'on appelle le green new
deal c'est une autre mesure phare qui
consiste à investir 500 milliards
d'euros dans la transition écologique et
ça ça crie ça créera de l'emploi dans
les bâtiments la rénovation thermique
dans les trains la santé le bio etc que
c'était donc ça si on fait ça si on
atteindre cet objectif 500 milliards ça
paraît beaucoup mais en fait ça
représente seulement 20% de ce que la
banque européenne la banque centrale
européenne a donné
à donner aux états et aux banques
privées afin de faire je ne sais pas
quoi je vous coupe pour qu'on est
ensemble elles diront que c'est dire
voilà l attendent tranquillement se
passe quand on est fils souvent
effectivement quand on parle d'emploi il
faut aussi parler de chômage on l'a dit
en europe 20 millions de chômeurs faut
parler de pauvreté dans les dix
dernières années le taux de pauvreté est
passé de 7 à 10%
et puis aussi des richesses qui quand
même ont été accumulés dans ces mêmes
dix dernières années on est passé de 15
mille milliards à 17 milliards donc
l'emploi oui on peut créer de l'emploi
effectivement l'europe telle qu'elle est
c'est le résultat quand même de
politique libérale depuis des décennies
ce que nous proposent au parti
communiste
c'est effectivement parce qu'on n'a pas
été les derniers quand même à proposer
le smic européen
effectivement on est sûr sur un calcul
qui sera harmonisée dans les différents
pays
tous n'ont pas un smic dans tous les
pays européens on n'est pas tous en
harmonisation mais il faudra arriver à
harmoniser c'est ce qui évitera le
dumping social et la concurrence des
salariés des pays laisse avec les
salariés les pays des pays de l'ouest
60% du salaire médian
ce qui fait aussi augmenter le smic en
france et quand vous disiez tout à
l'heure que certains états pouvaient pas
le faire
je vous rappelle que après mai 68 le
smic a été augmenté de 25 % la france
apparemment je vous sais ce que c'est
moi le voilà donc je veux dire c'est
tout à fait possible quand on a dix-sept
mille milliards de de richesse produite
en plus on peut faire des choses on a
aussi on parlera tout à l'heure des
frontières mais on allait viser
l'évasion fiscale la fraude fiscale les
paradis fiscaux
avec tout ce qui est tout ce qu'ils
s'évadent continuent quotidiennement et
tous les ans ça fait quand même 1000
milliards par an avec milliards on peut
faire des choses et notamment on peut
construire dix mille hôpitaux ça en fait
de l'emploi ça en fait de l'emploi et
les services publics à la française même
si tous les tous les états ne sont pas
d'accord avec ce modèle là le modèle
français est quand même très apprécié
juste un petit mot avant qu'on avance
dans la suite et je me tourne vers voir
nos d'argent parce que vous êtes député
sortant c'est que tout ça qu'est ce
qu'on vient de dire la messe que ça se
heurte pas pour l'instant à la règle de
l'unanimité en europe qui fait que
globalement on n'avance pas non mais
d'abord d'abord c'est faux parce que
l'unanimité ne prévaut pas dans tous les
domaines vous avez quand même beaucoup
de domaines aujourd'hui qu'ils se
décident à la majorité qualifiée mais là
principe le principal problème je dois
vous dire il n'est pas forcément
d'ailleurs de couleur politique droite
gauche tout ça il est souvent bien plus
lié à des cultures nationales ont parlé
des travailleurs détachés tout à l'heure
je rejoins ce que disait monsieur odoul
il a plutôt raison ce qui a été adoptée
jusqu'à présent est une réformette
c'est un début de réforme sur ce statut
des travailleurs ceux des travailleurs
détachés la problématique et les où on
sait que les problèmes à gré avec les
pib à sion les classiques moi j'étais au
vote qui a eu lieu au mois d'avril sur
le transport routier en particulier qui
a été exclu et rulan met d'accord qu'il
a exclu ce qu'on a on a fait un paquet
mobilité qui aujourd'hui remet les
travailleurs dans les étangs ce qu'ont
négociés les états et monsieur maquereau
en particulier sur mâcon qui nous dit
que c'est un grand succès sur le travail
des tâches et c'est lui qui a exclu le
transport pour faire un compromis avec
les autres donc nous on a essayé de
rétablir le transport dans ce paquet il
faut bien voir que le vote qui a eu lieu
ça a été un vote s'apprêtait à un vote
droite gauche ça a été un vote est ouest
toutes les forces françaises
pratiquement ont voté le même texte et
vous avez trouve qu'elles soient de
gauche ou droite et les autres qu'on a
eu en face de nous était plutôt
évidemment les polonais les tchèques
clio là il faut être conscient de ça les
difficultés elles tiennent beaucoup à ça
aussi et malheureusement moi ce que je
constate c'est que le modèle français
dont on se gargarise temps souvent chez
nous il ya plein de sujets sur lesquels
il est repoussoir pour les autres en
matière fiscale notamment
attention vous m'aviez dit c'était juste
pour qu'on se fasse un peu de contexte
européen aussi par rapport à tout ce que
tout ce que tout le monde peut souhaiter
autre sujet du jour il est de taille
l'agriculture pendant longtemps le coeur
de l'action européenne en tout cas
toujours la première dépense de l'union
362 milliards dont il faut le rappeler
et ça compte dans notre débat 70% sont
des aides directes aux agriculteurs
destiné à donner un revenu minimum alors
notre question on pourrait le formuler
comme ça c'est est ce qu'il faut changer
est-ce qu'il faut continuer à aider
l'agriculture de la même manière est ce
que l'europe doit pousser pour changer
le modèle agricole on va dire qu'il ya
là dessus des différences très forte
dans dans les listes je me tourne
forcément vers vous jérémy decerle pour
pour commencer ce débat vous êtes
agriculteur vous avez de vous vous êtes
d'ailleurs retrouvé ces derniers jours
dans une
la polémique autour d'eux des alliés ou
des adversaires de monsanto sur le
glyphosate et et j'utilise ce sujet
parce que le glyphosate ça nous
détermine une forme de modélisation
aussi de l'agriculture est ce qu'on doit
passer vers moins de produits phyto
moins de taille moins de choses comme ça
est ce que votre liste souhaite que
l'europe change
le modèle agricole qu'elle a promu
jusque là et on sait que ce modèle
agricole c'était quand même globalement
détails plus importante c'était pas
forcément promotion du bio c'était tout
ça deux choses pour démarrer nous serons
à ses pizzas ni qui disait ça nous
aurons besoin de toutes les agricultures
du monde pour nourrir le monde
c'est toujours vrai
par contre il ya aussi des attentes
sociétales forte en france certes mais
en europe aussi qui demande à ce que
l'agriculture et ceux qui la font
évoluer
par contre encore une fois faut pas
faire ça manu militari sans les
agriculteurs avec des vision dogmatique
et donc il faut enclencher tout ça de
manière encore une fois assez cohérente
et il faut que la politique européenne
la politique agricole commune soit un
peu plus en adéquation et avec les
attentes sociétales avec les
possibilités que les agriculteurs ont à
faire évoluer le modèle qu'est ce que
nous proposons nous c'est que dans la
prochaine politique agricole comme
une on s'attache à donner plus de
revenus aux agriculteurs si je dois
développer je le ferai a pas de souci
protéger encore plus les agriculteurs en
l'oeil en leur apportant à la fois des
systèmes des outils assurantiels qui
leur permettent mieux de faire face aux
différents risques climatiques aux
risques économiques et puis aux risques
sanitaires aussi mais à d'autres risques
l'europe doit permettre tout ça en
mettant des systèmes assurantiels en
place cohérent elle doit aussi protéger
les agriculteurs et les consommateurs
des produits qui arrivent d'autres pays
donc les accords commerciaux et des
accords commerciaux
voilà sur les accords commerciaux nous
devons nous demandons et nous proposons
de traiter l'agriculture et
l'alimentation différemment dans un
cadre dédié pour pas qu'on échange qu'on
continue d'échanger des avions de chasse
compte des kilos de viande
et puis la troisième partie c'est la
transition agricole et écologique qui
est doublement important vu les enjeux
qui a derrière mais s'il n'y a pas de
revenus si on n'accompagne pas et
protège pas les agriculteurs
il y aura difficilement de la transition
écologique
donc oui nous sommes très ambitieux sur
ce point là et nous souhaitons
effectivement que ça aille loin et en se
reposant aussi ce qu il se trouve qu'en
france nous avons l'agriculture et
l'alimentation la plus durable du monde
donc en se reposant aussi sur ces points
positifs nous pouvons et nous devons
aller plus loin je viens donc qu'est ce
qui caractériserait sur l'agriculture le
programme du national déjà le programme
de l oiseau c'est par ici
la wii nommé parce que vous venez de
dire des absurdités qui sont je dirais
en total désaccord avec ce que vous
projetez pour nos agriculteurs ce que
vous leur projetez-vous leur promettez
en tout cas le suicide
le suicide puisque le 8 mai dernier
monsieur de serge pas si vous le savez
le ministre de l'agriculture brésilienne
annonçait que l'union européenne donc
avait validé l'accord de libre échange
du mercosur avec le brésil avec
l'argentine l'uruguay et le paraguay au
courant peut-être assez facile
non mais c'est encore acté c'est en
cours ça fait 2 2
le ministre vient dire c'est s était
validé le mignon résilience lankaise se
tresser retraité de libre échange va se
faire au détriment de nos filières
viandes européenne est notée et
notamment françaises c'est un suicide
social puisque évidemment ça va
contribuer à appauvrir donc et a ajouté
une concurrence déloyale pour nos
agriculteurs
c'est un suicide sanitaire également
puisque quand on sait les scandales qui
a eu au brésil sur la viande avariée
c'est ce qui va aujourd'hui c'est ou
demain arrivé dans nos assiettes dans
les assiettes de nos quand il ya des
normes à nos frontières de l'europe
quand même julien dont il avait roulé
s'il n'avait plus avec six appareils en
des gens l'adorable et géant d'are il
yad'énormes quand même s'ils sont posées
quand même ici aussi c'est aussi un
suicide environnementale parce qu'il
faut savoir que un cargo un seul cargo
qui va faire venir de la viande du
brésil en france va polluer autant que 1
million de véhicules un million de
véhicules donc ça veut dire que votre
groupe pardon que pour être contraire
votre groupe s'opposera aux accords et
bien sûr comme il l'a déjà fait donc
nous nous sommes contre les accords de
libre échange
nous sommes pour du protectionnistes
faire en sorte qu'on passe du libre
échange au juste échange
compass du globalisme au localisme
conviennent à de la proximité et ferrand
chance qu'on consomme et nous réduisent
et qu'on retrait des violences sur le
dossier alors qu'on va pas ouvrir le
glyphosate mais sur le dossier du modèle
agricole
est ce que vous vous pousser pour que
l'europe l'union fasse changer de modèle
et demande aux agriculteurs d'abandonner
de l'ifo that d'abandonner les produits
au sénégal annoncé au niveau tellement
nous sommes contre l'europe des lobbys
alors que la république en marche et
totalement noyautée par les lobbys il
faut savoir que le groupe ld eu dans
lequel vous serez monsieur de cernes
bien sûr que si vous serez dans ce
groupe a eu le groupe est lourd et si on
est on sait est financé par bayer
monsanto voilà lemagnen évidemment de
des pesticides qui a été condamné il ya
1,2 milliard de dollars donc par pour
reverser un couple qui atteint de cancer
voilà c'est ça c'est ça la réalité
monsieur decerle de l'autre politique
entre votre verbiage pour agriculture
pro-vie roman que vous êtes une caution
on aura fait une connerie sur connerie
on le laisse répondre capron passe aux
autres on aura compris que vous avez
essayé de cibler une seule personne dans
ce débat julien au double pour se
comprendre le fonctionnement d'autres
campagnes m'en faire de positions non
plus donc et d'une ça fait deux ans et
demi un mot sur les accords
internationaux d'y aller on passe aux
mélodies la france ne fait rien et
laisse ces accords sont signés sauf que
ça fait deux ans que les accords ne sont
pas signé je dis pas qu'il n'ya pas de
risque je dis pas qu'il ne faut pas se
méfier
sauf que c'est pas encore les brésiliens
tout seul qui décide ça donc les accords
ne sont pas si loin et donc sur le
glyphosate on nous dit qu'on va adhérer
à la ldh qu'est ce qu'on a dit alain à
la ldc le groupe libéral au diable ce
groupe existe pas tout ça n'existe des
entraîneurs européens proches devient
alors on va pas tirer dessus dans sur la
comète
je vous propose qu'on attendait tous le
résultat je vous voyais je vouvoyais
isabelle diront tout petit tout le monde
a bien sûr oui je voulais sauter des
accords de libre échange qui vous ont
fait rêver damman et je voulais revenir
aussi sur le budget le budget c'est
quand même 37% 1 du budget européen
budget agricole et il faut savoir que la
commission européenne se propose dans la
période qui va suivre de 2021 et 2027 à
la baisser le budget de 15 % donc ça
c'est très très grave parce que nous pas
du tout ce qu'on veut la politique
agricole commune ya beaucoup de chose à
en dire et beaucoup de critiques a
apporté bien entendu puisque ça serait
si les agriculteurs vivait bien
l'agriculture depuis l'instauration en
1992 de la patte par exemple dans la
nièvre les exploitants ont diminué de
moitié en même temps je vous pousse un
peu il ya comme un 40% du budget de
l'union qui est consacrée à la grippe
et oui et pourquoi parce que c'est très
important l'agriculture puisque ça
permet de nourrir nourrir les êtres
humains donc on en a besoin on a besoin
d'une agriculture pas celle qui est qui
est fait actuellement puisque c'est
c'est dans la ligne des politiques
libérales mais c'est très important mais
les agriculteurs
il faut qu'ils puissent vivre
vivent de leurs activités comme tout un
chacun c'est tout à fait tout à fait
normal et la moitié quand même qui ne
vit pas au smic 1 donc ya pas que les
grosses exploitations il ya aussi les
agriculteurs familiaux et nous conte ce
qu'on propose aussi notamment avait
tendu la perche c'est d'exclure le
secteur agricole et l'alimentation des
accords de libre échange
on a parlé du mercosur s'il n'y est pas
celle dont je vous promets l'europe est
la première puissance agricole mondiale
on est bien obligé de discuter on peut
pas on peut pas ne pas avoir d'accord
bien sûr mais à ce moment là il faut il
faut revoir dans quelles conditions ces
accords sont sans pratiquer et c'est
effectivement pas comment échanger notre
filière bovine
on a quand même une filière bovine qui
est très intéressant en train d'
importantes mois dans la nièvre
elle est en crise depuis depuis des
années on n'a pas besoin de ça dans la
nièvre et ailleurs en bourgogne franche
comté pour aujourd'hui
c'est important que con reflet ch les
aides pour permettre aussi aux jeunes
agriculteurs de s'installer les filières
courtes d'autres endroits mais combien
on rappelle qu'à des fonds aussi pour
les zones en difficulté vis de fixation
des prix aussi c'est important je vous
avais balisée au début on est donc vous
vous aussi vous trouvez dans
l'agriculture
quelle est la position de génération sur
bon déjà nous on est pour que
l'agriculture soit l'un des leviers de
la transition écologique
si on se cache pas veut dire 7 vient de
saisir tout le monde de se met au vert
nous c'est notre conviction depuis le
début bon en proposant notamment ce
qu'on appelle un bouclier bio donc c'est
ce qui permettra de financer le passage
à l'agriculture biologique
on appelle aussi à soutenir les petites
productions de dire aussi une meilleure
répartition des aides de la pac une
meilleure répartition du foncier
plutôt que d'avoir une énorme ferme de
100 ha ben pourquoi pas on est pourquoi
on ne savait pas d'avoir d'installer
quatre jeunes dessus maintenant j'ai
serré je vais je vais m'attarder sur un
point parce que vous l'avez dit moi ça
fait 4 ça fait quatre ans que j'essaye
de m'installer en tant qu'exploitant
agricole j'arrive pas pourquoi une bonne
question
macron cette année au salon de
l'agriculture qu'est-ce qui nous a dit
j'ai dit qu'il fallait susciter des
vocations pour s'installer parce qu'il
ya de moins en moins d'agriculteurs
factuellement oui il a raison il ya de
moins en moins d'agriculteurs y en a
encore moins
à l'avenir donc il faut installer des
jeunes et susciter des vocations
ça fait quatre ans que je sillonne la
france du nord au sud afin d'acquérir
l'expérience nécessaire pour m'installer
j'ai fait absolument tout ce qu'on m'a
demandé j'ai coché toutes les cases
je me suis retrouvé devant la grille
culture j'ai monté un dossier pendant
huit mois maintenant j'imagine je vous
laisse je vous laisse répondre ce que
vous êtes en face de moi quel est
l'acteur qu'on va voir le dernier acteur
l'un des derniers acteurs qu'on va voir
pour pouvoir s'installer finaliser une
installation agricole personne c'est là
donc tout à fait exactement exactement
le problème c'est que les jeunes comme
moi je l'entreprise on est d'accord on
est d'accord pas d'accord
problème c'est que des jeunes comme moi
qui veulent s'installer aujourd'hui ils
ont à kerry ils ont acquis de
l'expérience ou dans les petites
exploitations sont souvent payés au smic
mois pendant ces quatre ans j'étais payé
au smic mais question de l'europe pardon
je veux pas monter mais parce que le
temps passe et régionales prennent en
quoi c'est important dans le programme
de sa gamme européen important parce
qu'aujourd'hui on est face à des jeunes
qui ne peuvent pas s'installer parce
qu'on leur demande des magouilles
démagogie bien démago de trente à
cinquante mille euros d'apport c'est ce
qu'on m'a demandé
donc qu'est ce que l'europe propose
qu'est ce que nous on propose on propose
deux déjà de déjà faire comprendre aux
banques que quand on s'appelle le crédit
agricole
mais ça ça c'est pas un programme
européen j'y viens aussi j'y viens parce
que j'ai pas terminé en recul mais je
vois la carcasse de faciliter les
installations en en répartition en mieux
ré basse en répartissant les aides de la
pac et surtout en faisant intervenir les
banques d'investissement qui elle
prendre en charge les installations qui
ne peut pas mais c'est sur
l'installation vous voulez vous voulez
particulièrement parce que ces modèles
entre 10 et 40 mille euros nets pour
tous jeunes qui s'installent regardez
regardez moi on m'a demandé pardon je
vous propose juste qu'on arrête ce débat
là parce qu'on avancera pas seulement
latine au genou et n'a jamais dit assia
nous donne la position de espace public
a su ou partagent le même diagnostic
notamment avec les forces de gauche
nous on propose
une politique agricole et alimentaire
commune pour être fidèle au serment
d'hippocrate qui disait tu feras de
l'alimentation ta première médecine en
favorisant le bio les circuits courts
donc nous on propose une taxe à niveau
zéro donc tv à 0 pour les produits issus
notamment de l'agriculture biologique
et puis aussi c'est la proposition 35 je
vous invite à lire sur le site
envie de re point eu un peu de pub ne
fait pas de mal on propose un plan de
formation pour les agriculteurs
justement pour qu'ils puissent je pense
qu'on peut nous rejoindre
j'ai déjà permis renforcer les moyens à
un dispositif pour que chacune et chacun
soit en mesure de pouvoir relever le
défi climatique parce qu'on l'a très peu
et véreux qui jusque là
bref choses ont déjà été dites quatre
points qu'il faut changer en fait la
question c'est la gazinière premier
point il faut une politique agricole
commune
ça paraît une évidence devenir servent
vraiment comme un manque vraiment
commune parce qu'il ya des risques que
cette politique agricole se défasse
qu'elle devienne nationalisé par chacun
des états et là on y sera évidemment pas
gagnant nous français parce que nous
avons certainement moins de moyens à
mettre que d'autres puissances qui
voudrait qu'il pourrait reprendre les
rênes de leur propre agriculture donc il
faut une politique agricole commune et
tous les grands états au monde toutes
les grandes puissances au monde ont une
politique publique agricole s'est pas
être anti libérale quoi que ce soit de
vouloir une politique agricole commune
les etats unis pays très libéral ont une
politique publique agricole très
puissante donc une politique agricole
commune 2 il faut que cette politique
agricole commune soit d'abord là pour
assurer un revenu aux agriculteurs aidés
à la production aider à la production
parce qu'être agriculteurs c'est d'abord
produire alors il ya plein de
fonctionner l'essentiel du butin qui
montrait que revenus actuellement non
mais attention moi je vous mets en garde
aujourd'hui dans les discussions qui
sont en cours et où j'en veux beaucoup
au gouvernement macron de ne pas avoir
fait le job depuis deux ans dans les
négociations les pré négociation du
budget agricole en particulier les
propositions qui sont faites par la
commission européenne
démantèle une partie de ce qu'on appelle
le premier pilier qui est ce qui est de
l'aide directe aux exploitations
tout ça sur des couvert d'écologie
d'ailleurs donc il faut être très
vigilant par rapport à ça troisième
point
donc il faut aider la production l'acte
de production 3
m point sur la transformation écologique
tout le monde est d'accord agriculture
environnement tout le monde est d'accord
les premiers d'accord c'est les
agriculteurs eux mêmes c'est leur outil
de travail la nature donc évidemment que
les agriculteurs s'adapter s'adapte
depuis déjà des décennies
moi je dis attention quand même à ce
qu'on demande parce qu'aujourd'hui il ya
un excès dans le sens inverse
on veut laver plus vert que vert en
europe quand je vois le programme dans
marche qui dit moi je suis désolé jérémy
vous êtes sur une liste dans laquelle
les clés ont été confiée à monsieur qu
enfin moi je les ai eus comme collègue
au parlement européen c'est un
écologiste certifier c'est des gens pour
lesquels l'europe doit devenir la
puissance verte mais vous devenez pas
une puissance verte quand en vous
mettant des règles qu'aucun autre
puissance au monde ne respecte donc on
veut être plus vertueux que tout le
monde
moralité moi je crains que ce genre de
dispositif alourdisse énormément les
charges et les contraintes du monde
agricole français qui n'en a pas besoin
je vous avais jean paulhan et la main
mais je vais vous couper parce que sinon
on n'avancera pas je vais vous ne devez
pas vous redonner la parole tout petit
je suis désolé avant de passer à notre
dernier chapitre et il nous reste 20
petites minutes d'émission on écoute
tout de même parce que dans le cadre d
équilibre on souhaitait aussi dans cette
émission
mais entendre la parole de ceux qui
souhaitent sortir de l'europe en
particulier la liste menée par florian
philippot leader des patriotes
on écoute tout de suite plus on entre
dans la campagne européenne plus les
français se rendent compte que ya pas 36
solutions soit l'union européenne on s'y
soumet gens là qui tu nous proposes de
la quitter pour le bien de la démocratie
le bien de la france et le bien des
français tout simplement si on s'y
soumet si on dit même qu'on veut la
réforme et de l'intérieur ans j'entends
ça côté rassemblement national france
insoumise debout la france est à public
avec tout le monde dit ça maintenant et
arrêté au moment parce que ça fait 40
ans qu'on promet ça et ses carences ça
fait 40 ans que c'est un faisable il
faudrait l'unanimité des 28 états pour
réformer c'est impossible on va battre
campagne
on n'a pas d'argent mais on n'a pas de
on n'a pas de soutien bancaire mais on a
des idées
voilà et on a des convictions solidement
accrochés au coeur et je vous dire ça
fera toute la différence et notre
conviction première c'est que la france
doit être libre elle doit être
indépendante sortie du nuit en peine
pour être prospère
candidate pour gris franche comté je
note que monsieur philippot est pas
capable d'en produire 1 et qu'il faut
que c'est lui mais il ya une part dans
après c'est un petit peu de la cuisine
interne ya une candidate franc comtoise
sur la liste de 2 florian philippot
voilà pour pour rectifier néanmoins
aller on termine et on va être obligé de
terminer rapidement parce qu'il nous
reste plus beaucoup de temps si vous
pouvez vous voulez tous conclure on
avait décidé de parler des frontières
volontairement
enfin on on a mis un petit peu à la fin
parce que quand on regarde les chiffres
et j'avais envie de lancer le sujet un
peu de cette manière là depuis 2015 on
sait que les arrivées de migrants en
europe ont chuté de plus de 80%
donc la question est je lance la
discussion comme ça est ce que c'est
vraiment encore un sujet ou pas
miam elias a je tiens rappliquent
oui c'est un sujet puisque je n'aime pas
parler
évoquer justement cette tragédie
2 du cimetière de la méditerranée en
faisant des statistiques mais je vais
quand même rappeler un chiffre il ya dix
sept mille personnes qui sont mortes en
méditerranée entre 2014 et 2018
après le geste me dit j'ai substitue pas
votre pour la liste ps place publique on
met l'humain au coeur du projet et c'est
un enjeu fondamental et c'est
directement corrélés aux enjeux de
transition climatique au dérèglement
climatique aux guerres aux enjeux de
politique internationale et comment dire
la survie de l'europe et de l'humanité
est très importante
répondre à ce défi
ce n'est pas simplement augmenter les
effectifs de frontex et pourtant c'est
un sujet puisque accepté dispute en
europe pour savoir si on doit le faire
cette huile simplement une partie de la
solution mais au-delà de ça je pense
enfin je pense notre liste pense qu'il
faut renforcer donc les efforts pour
transformer les systèmes de production
il faut aussi encourager la coopération
décentralisée entre les différents états
aussi proposé des visas humanitaires et
puis surtout être fidèle nous français
parce qu'il faut oublier que nous sommes
les héritiers de la troisième république
nous sommes les enfants de victor hugo
elle nous devons éclairez nous devons
assumer nos responsabilités et ne pas
comment dire céder aux tentatives
électeurs avant c'est parce qu'on va pas
on va pas arriver au bout de ce chat
bien sûr que l'on puisse conclure
d'accord d'accord mais en tout cas on ne
va pas céder à la facilité en disant il
faut fermer les frontières est devenu de
plus en plus dresser pied donc vous
n'êtes pas vous n'êtes pas pour la
fermeture miloud aultman mois dans votre
programme on est donc des plus d'accueil
jeunes exactement nous on s'en cache pas
et puis on ne discute pas avec
la vie des personnes notamment ceux qui
meurent en méditerranée bon il ya quand
même deux arguments qui nous sont
souvent balancer à la figure à savoir le
premier c'est le cas sur la question de
la sécurité la deuxième c'est le
deuxième argument c'est celui du coup on
sait des arguments complètement de
données dans la mesure où ans et et le
cnrs l'a déjà montré que l'immigration
rapportent plus aux pays d'accueil
qu'elle ne lui coûte finalement ça c'est
factuel deuxième des choses au niveau de
la sécurité ben c'est pareil parce qu'on
va nous dire les vrais à vendre sans
doute ne dira qu' il ya des attentes
bon c'est vrai il ya eu des attentats
mais la majorité des attentats qui ont
été perpétuée par exemple en france
c'est le fait de france et non pas
d'immigrés donc plutôt que de montrer
une certaine une certaine forme
d'hypocrisie sur cette question et bien
proposons c'est ce qu'on propose la
génération une réelle politique
d'accueil des migrants en respectant la
vie des humains et en préservant les
intérêts des pays d'accueil sur le même
isabelle diront c'est aussi sur le
programme du parti communiste donc sur
une ouverture de l'europe bien sûr parce
que ce qu'il faut bien savoir et il a
rappelé tout à l'heure on a une
tradition d'accueil en france on est
tous descendants de migrants de toute
façon s'ils remontent au plus loin et
puis on a aussi affaire à un enjeux
climatiques qui nous qui nous arrive
dessus donc de toutes façons des
migrations elles vont se faire
contrainte et forcée autant préparé
préparer l'accueil et puis j'allais dire
aussi il faut il faut faire comment
se poser la question du pourquoi aussi
des migrations vous avez vous avez
plusieurs formes de migration
mais quand d'un côté on organise le
pillage des richesses dans les pays
d'origine que le réchauffement
climatique arrive parce qu'on surproduit
on surconsomme et ensuite qu'on dit aux
personnes aux populations qui en sont
les victimes à rester chez vous
débrouillez vous c'est pour le moins
c'est scandaleux inhumain et voilà on a
des choses à faire on a des
responsabilités et il faut les il faut
les assumer complètement
je comprends bien des dit que nous
sommes les pires au monde que nous
sommes inhumain nous pillons les autres
et nous ne sommes pas généreuse nous
l'accueillons fait l'endroit
donnez moi mais je pense que les
européens sont très généreux je pense
que l'europe est un des continents les
plus ouverts et les plus généreux qui
soit au monde
jedi jeunes acceptent d'ailleurs pas ce
titre de cette partie du débat une
europe cadenassé ou accueillant le débat
il n'est pas celui ci le débat il est
comment on gère des flux migratoires qui
sont devenus excessif par rapport aux
capacités d'absorption de nos sociétés
c'est ça la vérité aujourd'hui est donc
la question n'est pas de tout fermer de
tout ouvrir parce qu'on n'y arrivera pas
comme ça on n'arrivera pas tous fermés
et tout ouvrir ce serait une folie
pourquoi tous les demandeurs d'asile au
monde viendrait trouvé asile en europe
pourquoi ce serait à l'europe d'assumer
cette charge donc écouter lorient
simplement il faut simplement être
réaliste par rapport à ça nous nous
propose proposant ce qu'on appelle une
double protection c'est à dire que vous
devez avoir un système de protection des
frontières extérieures de l'europe
assumée par l'europe au niveau collectif
et puis chaque état doit rester
parfaitement souverain sur sa politique
migratoire dont il faut constater
malheureusement en france qu'elle a été
trop laxiste pendant des années mais
chaque état doit rester maigres sa
politique migratoire c'est à dire qui a
le droit de rester dans sa société et
sur son sol et c'est pas à bruxelles ni
à aucune autre capitale européenne
d'imposer cela je vous coupe
effectivement parce que vous êtes une
très en avance sur le temps mais en tant
que député sortant s'était s'était pas
illogique johnny au double bien sûr pas
d'accord avec déjà il faut sortir des
caricatures c'est à dire que la
frontière c'est pas un mur c'est pas un
cauchemar
la frontière c'est juste du bon sens
c'est une porte c'est savoir qui vient
qui peut rentrer dans la maison france
qui ne peut pas rentrer dans la maison
france là on
une porte chez soi c'est c'est juste du
bon sens et nous ce qu'on souhaite c'est
sortir finalement de cette illusion
donc tous nous a bercés pendant des
années de la petite clôture autour de
l'europe qui a été celle guen qui n'a
été qu'une passoire qui a fait rentrer
des milliers de migrants qui a fait
rentrer malheureusement aussi les
djihadistes nous nous souhaitons
remettre des portes et des fenêtres à la
maison france parce qu'encore une fois
nous sommes dans une fin de la libre
circulation nous sommes dans un canton
de submersion serre que l'an dernier
dans la faute de la politique migratoire
insensé de monsieur macron du 400 mille
immigrés qui sont rentrés en france et
ce n'est que le début
et compte tenu de la situation de notre
pays de notre région notamment où on
déplore 370000 pauvre 230 mille chômeurs
ne pouvons plus accueillir une poule ont
pu accueillir ne pouvons plus héberger
nous ne pouvons plus installés nous ne
pouvons plus faire passer les autres
avant les nôtres donc il faut que la
solide solidarité nationale elles soient
réservés ac/dc d'entre nous qui ont le
plus besoin mans tout de même sur le
débat qui est en ce moment sur frontex
et des moyens nets supplémentaires pour
cette agence européenne qui vient
renforcer les dp des nationaux à leurs
frontières les pays de l'est en
particulier vers lesquels parti à viktor
orban vers lesquels marine le pen se
tourne beaucoup sont reposés à plus de
moyens pour frontex
mais aussi et vous aimez aussi c'est pas
vrai annoncé sur le tronc bon d'accord
variant de gens me regardent méchamment
pour un mot sur ce contexte
oui mais il ya des choses qu'ils veulent
pas dans frontex sceller les pouvoirs de
frontex l'effet de pouvoir s'en donner
un aspect factuel mais contexte n'est
pas là pour se substituer aux états il
vient à l'appui des états sur leurs de
gens qu'on vous a crû de 40 comparé d'un
temps de plateau c'était une explication
technique c'est un problème avec ce
contexte c'est que frontex finalement ne
lutte pas contre l'immigration
clandestine
mais elle finalement la favorise
puisqu'elle fait le jeu des passeurs
elle va chercher les bateaux de migrants
et elle ramène sur nos côtes
alors qu'il faudrait qu'elle fasse
linverse qui les ramène sur les ports de
départ et on parlait tout à l'heure des
morts en méditerranée évidemment que ce
que c'est terrible et c'est dramatique
nous on souhaiterait qu'à voir la même
politique migratoire qu en australie qui
a une politique de fermeté où il ya plus
de morts donc dans les eaux
territoriales a été très critiqué a
répliqué avec des humanitaires il nous
reste deux minutes
nos conclusions donc c'est juste bien
jérémy decerle je pense jusque sur cette
question là comme sur les questions
d'emploi de social et de travail tout à
l'heure il faut essayer d'avoir une à la
fois un constat pragmatique est pas
exagéré en exagérer les choses dans tous
les sens on dit qu'il faut rendre
laisser rentrer tout le monde et de
l'autre côté on dit qu'on en laisseront
servent à traiter certains vous vous
dites à les paramètres de fermeture et
d'autres disques et d'autres diront déjà
faut donc faut arrêter wave à des formes
peut-être mais tout le monde ma tach
donc ailleurs aussi parce que vous le
valez fort mais c'est très bien c'est
très bien mais c'était une invention
temps en elle-même un document parce que
les accords de dublin ce quelque chose
donc du coup il faut essayer
effectivement de ne pas refaire les
mêmes erreurs
avoir un peu plus de solidarité entre le
pays est effectivement renforcer notre
contrat dire qu'elle gêne à tron est
devenu un peu plus floue là-dessus à une
époque il était pour des relocalisations
la position note est un peu plus
pragmatique et essayer d'être un peu
plus solidaire déjà entrepris
effectivement renforcée quand même les
frontières extérieures mais on ne peut
pas dire que schengen c'est une
véritable passoire
ça aurait aussi eu des effets positifs
merci à tous les six d'avoir essayé de
répondre à ne répondre à nos questions
l'exercice n'est pas facile à 6 c est
sur des sujets aussi touffu on approche
de la fin de ce débat qui va donc se
terminer par une conclusion conclusion
pour tous dans un autre on nous avons
tirés au sort avant l'émission
je vous propose donc de commencer par
vous il avait le diront pour conclure
donc pour conclure donc ce que je
voulais dire c'est que le parti
communiste
et la liste de ian brossât et fait
partie de ceux qui font du parti
communiste qui est le seul parti à
gauche qui a rejeté tous les traités
européens qui ont construit l'europe
libérale que notre liste est la seule à
être composée de 50 % d'employés de
salariés de d'ouvriers et d'ouvrières
etc la liste qui permettra l'élection de
la première ouvrière au parlement
européen depuis 30 ans marianne bon là
et que les personnes qui se
reconnaissent en nous et en nos valeurs
contre une europe libérale je les engage
à mettre un bulletin geng he salle 26
mai merci j'avais le diront parfait je
vous rappelle que vous êtes bons coups
figurer sur la liste du parti communiste
ont mené par ian brossât dans notre
offre toujours milito deux semaines à
vous de conclure l'europe à la base
c'était une idée une idée selon laquelle
il fallait regrouper des pays qui
ensemble pourrait mener les batailles
que individuellement il ne pourrait pas
mener donc c'est dans cette logique que
nous on va aborder à génération cette
élection européenne en notre programme
qui est le printemps européenne le
printemps européen pardon c'est le seul
programme transnationales aujourd'hui
donc ce qu'on dit nous on le retrouve
dans d'autres pays européens
et c'est ce qui permettra de relever les
défis sociaux et environnemental de
notre époque
merci mais losemann vous figurez donc je
me rappelle à chaque fois sur la liste
de benoît hamon génération arnaud
danjean vous de conclure le 26 mai
prochain les électrices et les électeurs
auront le choix de voter pour des
européennes
il ne s'agit pas du match retour de la
présidentielle d'il ya deux ans il ne
s'agit pas d'un référendum par rapport à
la situation nationale en france même si
je comprends que le président de la
république s'implique beaucoup dans
cette campagne et que
il méritera aussi la sanction qui lui
revient mais je pense qu'il ya au delà
de cet enjeu national qui va peser on le
sait bien il y a un enjeu européen
vous allez élire des députés des hommes
et des femmes qui doivent défendre vos
intérêts pendant cinq ans à strasbourg
et à bruxelles donc moi j'insisterai sur
le côté utile et pragmatique que vous
devez donner à votre vote pour qu'à
chaque fois qu'un texte arrive au
parlement européen vous ayez des députés
qui en conscience vote utilement et
efficacement pour sauver les intérêts de
la france et de nos concitoyens c'est le
sens de la liste que nous menons avec
françois-xavier villes amies merci
arnaud danjean vous figurez donc sur la
liste elle est ramenée par
françois-xavier bel ami julien dole
tavaux de conclure le 26 mai les
français et notamment les bourguignons
et les franc-comtois peuvent voter deux
fois en un seul tour deux fois puisqu'il
ya la fois un référendum pour ou contre
emmanuel macron c'est emmanuel macron
qu'il l'a souhaité il a transformé
élections européennes
donc en votes sur sa personne et sa
politique en prenant part à la campagne
en mettant toute son énergie pour
combattre leurs actions nationales et en
s'affichant d'ailleurs sur sur des
tracts donc il faut sanctionner cette
politique vous sanctionner le mépris
faut sanctionner l'autisme de ce
président qui n'a rien compris à la
crise sociale démocratique que nous
subissons et puis il faut aussi changer
de modèle européen
faut arrêter avec cette technocratie
l'union européenne qui a fait tant de
mal à notre peuple depuis 30 ans il faut
construire une robe du bon sens une
europe des nations des peuples et des
libertés
ce sera possible avec un votre à saumon
nationale et l'a10 porté par jordan
mandela merci julien d'où donc conclue à
chaque fois pardon de la liste donc sur
la liste du rassemblement national
jérémy de serre c'est à vous bien écouté
au vu de ce qui vient d'être dit
notamment les françaises et les français
aient effectivement les bourguignons et
les franc-comtois auront la possibilité
de choisir de voter pour l'europe ou de
voter effectivement comme ça a été dit à
votre sanction
contre emmanuel macron nous avons dans
cette liste des hommes et des femmes qui
ont choisi qui se sont engagés avec une
signature à l'appui allez à l'europe
pour régler les problématiques
européennes et faire en sorte
effectivement que l'europe rendent la
sérénité mérité à chacune et chacun
ma foi si d'autres ont envie de faire de
cette élection un rapport de force
rassemblement national emmanuel macron
et bien tant pis pour eux nous si en
votant pour nous en tout cas vous avez
la certitude que des hommes et des
femmes irons là-bas pour régler des
problèmes et apporter un certain nombre
de solutions et ne pas faire comme
d'autres qu'ils ont et qui ont été
pendant quelques années au parlement
pour en apporter finalement pas grand
chose merci jérémy decerle mejia médias
cas c'est vous qui concluait ses
conclusions je dirais simplement à tout
le monde qu'il n'y a qu'un seul tour le
26 mai que l'enjeu est crucial qu'il ne
faut pas se limiter aux enjeux nationaux
ce n'est pas un pour ou contre emmanuel
macron c'est plutôt quel projet je veux
défendre en apportant bulletins de vote
pour élire mais représentants quel sera
le vote efficace le vote efficace ce
sera celui selon selon vos goûts
sensibilité parce que le clivage gauche
droite existe toujours j'en suis désolé
les deux groupes majoritaires au
parlement européen à celle ppe et le
groupe social-démocrate haut niveau les
sociaux démocrates
on a une opportunité historique de
devenir enfin majoritaire au niveau du
parlement européen
donc si vous ne voulez pas du statu quo
par rapport au libéralisme et si vous
vous souhaite enfin pour appliquer les
accords au tourne à coke vatea même si
les états unis se sont retirés
il faut voter de manière efficace avec
des représentants qui pourront notamment
porté la social écologie auprès de leurs
collègues et je rappelle que sur notre
liste nous avons deux prix nobel de
l'écologie merci mejia médias sia pour
cette conclusion cette fois c'est la fin
de ce débat merci à tous les six d'avoir
pris un peu de temps dans cette dernière
ligne
des élections européennes pour venir sur
le plateau de france 3 bourgogne franche
comté
rappelons que 34 listes sont en lice
pour ces élections
dimanche prochain pas d'émission
puisqu'il ya élection profitez-en donc
pour aller voter
et puis les résultats les réactions ce
sera sur france 3 bien sûr télé et
internet avec des valeurs un sondage
pour france télé mais les résultats
officiels plus tard particulier avec
l'heure de fermeture des bureaux je
crois que c'est en italie
c'est beaucoup plus tardif est resté
avec nous pour la partie nationale de
dimanche en politique bon dimanche au
revoir et merci
[Musique]